welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition aka your
friendly neighborhood spoiler man
and this video we're breaking down the
movie that started it all
that is 2008's iron man iron man
kickstarted the mcu and had it not been
for the film's success
it's unlikely that the marvel universe
would be the way that it is today
revisiting the movie after binge
watching the infinity saga
makes it so much better and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down some of the aspects that only
really pay off once you've taken a trip
through all 23 films
there's some amazing shots that
poetically pay things off down the line
items and elements that reoccur
throughout and overall the film is a
shining example
of why this series is such an incredible
piece of film
we will be going into heavy spoiler
territory for all 23 films
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
them then i highly recommend that you
turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
it without the way thank you for
clicking this
now let's get into our breakdown of iron
man
okay so the movie opens by thumping back
in black by ac dc
this very much becomes a theme of stock
throughout the film
and it's later used by happy and far
from home as peter parker creates his
new suit
this makes the passing of the torch feel
full circle and we are almost
immediately hit with a shot of tony
stark's hand holding a glass of single
malt scotch on the rocks
this is the same beverage that he pours
himself in avengers when confronting
loki
and it shows that the character does
have a preferred drink
however the fact we open on stock with
his hand holding a glass of alcohol
also symbolizes his journey through the
mcu
stark was an alcoholic and this is very
much hammered home here
his hand is the main focus of the shot
and this point would be brought full
circle by his final acting
endgame the first time we see stark it's
his hand doing something
self-destructive to himself
that shows his self-centered attitude
one of the last times that we see him is
through his hand doing something
self-destructive for the good of others
which shows how far the character has
come it's the perfect way to both
introduce the character and say goodbye
to him hammering home just how much of a
journey he's gone on
in the humvee he takes a selfie with a
soldier who he makes fun of for holding
up a peace sign
stark says he'd be out of the job with
peace but we see how far he's come
upon exiting the cave as he holds up a
peace sign to an aircraft overhead
in age of ultron he says peace in our
time and in endgame when repairing his
relationship with cap he says he just
wants peace
after the group are ambushed we see a
stark rocket land beside him before it
explodes
this is similar to the stark rocket that
we hear haunted scarlet witch in
quicksilver when they were children and
age of ultron
we cut to 36 hours earlier and an award
show that's being held in las vegas
here we learn of tony's past as well as
how it starts
in an article tony is seen building his
robot on dumb e
and we see mention of stock building two
prototype ais
this could be a nod to ultron and jarvis
the both of whom stark ends up creating
but it could also be a reference to
friday who ends up replacing jarvis
after he becomes the vision
dumb e of course becomes a nice bit of
set dressing throughout the ironman
trilogy and it's nice that stark still
keeps around his first invention
he of course does this with all his
suits too until he destroys them at the
end of the third movie
i just hope dummy didn't go the same way
r.i.p
howard's death is discussed in the video
and we can see that this was reported on
a newspaper date at the 17th of december
1991. in captain america civil war we
see from cctv footage that the winter
soldier killed the starks on the 16th of
december 1991
so it's nice that this continuity detail
has held up across all the films in
between
tony taking the reins of the company in
the wake of his father's death
is referred to as the prodigal son
returning in iron man 3 tony refers to
the mark 42 as a prodigal son
and this is a nice echoing of the famous
saying cut to tony in a casino
and we can actually hear the iron man
theme from the 60s playing in the
background
we meet christine everhart who does a
lovely spread on tony
and she of course appears in iron man 2
as someone that's doing
a lovely spread on justin hammer at the
end of the movie tony announces that
he's iron man
and the entire audience stand up except
for christine who remains seated
this is because she had already figured
out that tony was iron man
and therefore wasn't that surprised
after they spend the night together
we're introduced to jarvis who we learn
in endgame is named after the stark's
butler
in the basement tony works away on the
hot rod and we can hear the song
institutionalized by suicidal tendencies
this could be a nod to tony stark's
willingness to sacrifice his own life at
several points throughout the mcu
this happens at the end of this movie
the avengers
and of course endgame which saw the
final appearance of the character
peppa asks if tony will finally speak at
mit and he sort of brushes her off and
refuses to sign an agreement
stark would eventually speak there in
civil war which
would lead to his bath demonstration and
then eventually make mysterio hate his
guts
so if he'd agreed to the appearance then
perhaps he could have avoided causing
trouble for peter
iron man is often cited as creating his
own worst enemies
and this is an almost butterfly effect
occurrence that caused so many problems
down the line on the plane tony and rody
listened to ghostface killer
who often refers to himself as iron man
he was also supposed to have a cameo in
the film
but this was later removed also can we
like
acknowledge how badly terence howard
messed up by quitting after this film
like damn also shout out iron man 2
for for maybe the best recast scene of
all time
look it's me i'm here deal with it let's
move on
after demonstrating the jericho tony
gets his drink which we would then see
at the start of the movie
and he gets into the fun v leading to
the events that kickstarted the movie
he wakes up after being saved by dr yin
sin who remarks that they met before at
a technical
conference in burn stark says he doesn't
remember and
jinson says that he's not surprised as
if he'd been that drunk he wouldn't
remember either
we actually see this meeting play out in
iron man 3 and yeah to be fair
tony he was pretty drunk tony is
kidnapped by the 10 rings who are led by
the mandarin from iron man 3
though this could be getting retcon for
shanxi which is set to reveal the
actual 10 rings and the real mandarin
tony is told to build a jericho
missile but he instead builds the mark 1
and a new reactor
we learned that palladium is used to
power the arc reactor and this element
is actually laced throughout the film
in the movie we can see that the giant
arc reactor is filled with palladium gas
and tanks containing a place behind tony
when he talks to obadiah
at the end of the movie when peppa
overloads the reactor she does it by
pressing a button that says palladium
gas
in iron man 2 we learned that iron man
is suffering from palladium poisoning
and the element ties back to his origin
story in a lot of ways
the arc reactor returns at several
points throughout the mcu
and in this film we see that obadiah
struggles to replicate stark's design
and make the reactor smaller
if you've been following our breakdown
sudden you'll know that tony improves
his tech every film
and we can actually see in civil war
that he built an arc reactor small
enough to fit into a wristwatch
showing how far he has come the arc
reactor scene of course features peter
billingsley
who after getting a tie wafted in his
face ends up becoming a disgruntled sock
employee who is team mysterio and far
from home
the arc reactor imagery also pops up in
an amazing easter egg and end game
when the avengers put their hands
together you can see the similarities in
the looks here
and it's nice that this imagery
reappears throughout the series
though it saves tony's life after it's
removed in iron man 3
we can still see the scars of where it
sat on his chest in both civil war
and at the start of endgame when tony is
arguing with cap
the scenes in the cave with tony and
jinson of course mirror the ones in
endgame when tony is adrift in space
with nebulae
he also hammers the mask and this
clanging sound can be heard after the
credits of endgame
bringing everything full circle there's
also more imagery that would reappear in
endgame
and that is the positioning of his mask
when placed down
when tony gives his farewell message to
his family the helmet reappears in a
similar setup
mirroring the first and last appearance
of the helmet when assembling the suit
tony tells the ensign every other bolt
and no belts and whistles
this is why the suit falls apart when it
crash lands on the outside
as it's not being completely assembled
due to the pair having to work fast
yinson buys tony some time and runs at
the soldiers of firing at the cave roof
he doesn't fire out the soldiers
themselves because he's a doctor
and doctors take hippocratic ghosts to
never harm anyone
in doctor strange the character says
that he too took an oath to save lives
and not take them i like how all the
doctors in the franchise follow the same
rules that we do in the real world
another nice little touch is that yinson
dies in a very similar manner to how
irkscan dies in captain america
the parallels in these shots are really
well put together
and they show some of the staples of how
their origin stories mirror one another
there's also an american flag symbol
behind jinson's head
which may be a reference to captain
america iron man escapes the cave
is rescued and sent back to the good old
us of a
the first thing he gets is a
cheeseburger which is of course what
morgan asks for an
end game at the character's funeral
showing how similar they are
a subtle little joke comes when obadiah
asks tony if he's got one for him
and stark says there was only one but he
then pulls another one out at the
conference
we also meet phil coulson who would go
on to star in pretty much
all of these phase one movies and agents
of shield
who's hyped for season seven anyway tony
also says that he never got to say
goodbye to his father
and this clearly hangs over him in civil
war he uses bath to get therapy over it
before he finally meets with the
character in
endgame tony begins to build the suit
and there's a nice scene in which he
puts his hand into a holographic version
of the arm
peter would later do something similar
and far from home when creating his own
suit
stock goes upstairs to find obadiah
playing a piano piece by salieri
salieri was a composer who was
overshadowed by mozart during his career
and this jealousy allegedly led him to
kill his rival
this theme of betrayal is of course
shown in stein's actions throughout the
film
he finally double crosses tony at the
end of the movie and tells him that the
ark reactor is his ninth symphony
in classical music it's thought that a
composer will die after writing their
ninth symphony
and thus obadiah believes that the arc
reactor will be the last thing that the
character creates
the shots chosen for this scene also
mirror tony's battle with thanos in
infinity war
firstly obadiah pulls out the arc
reactor which sends the character into
critical condition
this is similar to how thanos stabs tony
in the film
obadiah then leans over the character
taunting him
over his death and this is repeated with
thanos who does the same thing to stark
the final shots are set up in the same
way and they happen when tony is at
death's door
so we have everything coming full circle
with the first big bad that tony fought
in iron man mirroring the last big bad
that he did in infinity war and end game
it really is one of the best easter eggs
that i've seen in the film and it shows
the attention to detail that marvel put
into their movies
tony takes his first flight and his
heads-up display warns him before he
hits a pillar
it flashes red in a blink and you'll
miss a moment and it's just a nice
little easter egg that shows marvel's
attention to detail
when tony flies past the ferris wheel we
can also see that the speed of the suit
is set to mac and it's below 1.
later tony of course passes this and
he's able to reach mach 1 and break the
sound barrier
when tony's suit ice is over and the
power cuts out we can actually also see
his eyes through the helmet
this was something i never really
noticed until getting a 4k copy of the
film and it's a great little detail
tony returns home to find a gift from
pepper which he pushes off into the lake
at his funeral
when tony is speaking we can also see
jarvis copying his speech and
transcribing it so that the ai can reply
the tv sounds up and the system does not
register this
showing that jarvis has been programmed
to only recognize tony's voice
the suit design is initially painted
gold which tony says is a little
ostentatious
and this is a call back to his golden
suit design from the comics
the tv displays a news report that says
tony has been bedridden since his return
so to prove it wrong he goes to the
party that it's reporting from
here he meets coulson who arranges an
appointment for him but he's so
distracted by peppa
that he just agrees to it this is why
coulson shows up later and saves peppa
and peppa is also wearing a dress that
is blue which he says is a birthday
present from him
in endgame we learn that tony has made
peppa the rescue suit as an anniversary
gift
and it's the same color as the dress
that she wears in this scene
christine shows him photos of his
weapons being used by the ten rings
and he learns that the company is double
dealing under the table
tony decides to go after them and he
works on his suit
we can actually see the energy moving
from the arc reactor into his repulsor
blaster
showing how they are powered tony flies
out and destroys the weapons himself
and he comes face to face with a tank he
takes it out in one shot
and this is because the character helped
to design the tank and therefore knows
its weak points
he's then attacked by the air force and
though this
isn't really an mcu easter egg one of
the soldiers is the same guy that played
coleman reece in the dark knight
man did that guy have a good 2008 stock
returns home
and is dismantled we can actually see a
prototype of captain america's shield
behind him
which of course returns in iron man 2.
obadiah is allegiance with the ten
ringses on earth after peppa goes
through his files
some of the names of the files are
callbacks to jeff bridge's other movie
the big lebowski such as the oh dude
and msc lebowski it turns out that stain
is building the iron manga armor
and the way that it moves and jumps is
actually similar to the way that the
hulkbuster armor would later in the
series
repeating the more bulky movements of
the machine stock and stain go head to
head
and at one point tony takes off a glove
after thinking he's defeated the villain
we can actually hear stark's real voice
and then the system's voice is split
second after
showing the delay between the suitcoms
at one point obadiah's targeting system
is damaged
and he has to eyeball the shot in civil
war this too happens to tony
and he has to manually aim his weapon
pepper overloads the reactor and
likely adds to tony's palladium
poisoning but he lives to fight another
day
a blue light shoots into the sky and
yeah that's
that's been done about 700 times in
comic book movies since
they held a press conference and agent
coulson says that he has 90 seconds
before the meeting
this actually takes 90 seconds before
the conference itself
and tony announces i am iron man
which would appear as the final line in
iron man 3
ending the characters trilogy and also
it would end up being the last thing
that he says before his death in endgame
he goes home to find nick fury there who
tells him about the avengers initiative
which of course sets up the entire mcu
and the incredible 23 films in the
infinity saga
and that's our list obviously i'd love
to hear what easter eggs were your
favorite
and if we missed any comment below and
let us know and if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out some of the
insane details that we noticed in thor
ragnarok
it's one of our best videos we've ever
made so definitely check it out after
this
if you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come tattoos after the
show either follow us at definition yt
or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers
so hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thank you for taking the
time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you